attention c'est quoi les difficultés
aujourd'hui clairement le format de cet
animal la dernière chance
[Musique]
de la tanière
près de la dernière c'est maison de
retraite un hôpital une solution
d'accueil pour les animaux qui n'en ont
pas qui n'en ont plus
animaux qu'on a récupéré au fin fond de
l'Espagne qui ont été enlevés tous bébés
à leur moment il devait au biberon
castrer bébé ce qu'il faut surtout pas
faire du coup ils ont pas de crinière et
surtout ils ont été dégriffés par des
charlatans et donc ça c'est beaucoup
affecté ils ont servi par 3 ou 4 mois à
faire des photos sur les plages dans les
boîtes de nuit le soir donc sur des
problèmes aussi de cataracte etc à cause
des flash et puis
à cause de l'affection bactérienne qui a
pu y avoir avec ses griffes c'est
développé une boule de calcification ou
peut-être plusieurs ici qui empêchent la
colonne vertébrale de
fonctionner normalement donc il est
paralysé du train arrière si jamais on
devait faire des hauts ça serait
mais là ça serait très difficile
et puis en cours de dilatation
[Musique]
ma dernière chance pour lui
la dernière chance
ça fonctionne pas il y a aussi un risque
de comprenne la décision pour la
réveiller c'est ce qu'on découvre
une pâte ici une table de vente
là on est en train de vis on est en
train de faire le temps
on me pose des cathéter donc l'idée
c'est que on stabilise toutes les voix
d'accès aussi bienveineuse que aérienne
pour la saisie pour justement au cas où
en urgence pouvoir le rendre dormir ou
le réveiller s'il y a un souci et on va
aller chercher
le rachis c'est possible
alors aujourd'hui donc on a le plus
grand chirurgien vétérinaire de France
qui est là pour tenter cette opération
donc on désinsère tout ce qui est sur le
pin on bascule comme ça la musculature
on prend l'épaule et on la fait tourner
complètement
on désinserre le gros muscle rhomboïde
là qui maintient l'épaule dans sa partie
haute et donc du coup la scapula est
libre on peut la basculer comme ça et là
ça permet d'arriver sur le rachis par
voie latéral sur un animal de ce point
là qui est d'une longueur incroyable
mais par contre il y a une un poste
opératoire où l'animal se sert quasiment
pas de sa patte avant
[Musique]
attention
normalement à 909 % de chance il sera
arrivé après ça voilà c'est très très
gros intervention
avec moi sommier bon on a été tout à
fait clair il m'a dit en fonction de ce
que je vais voir et de ce que ils m'ont
dit je vous le dirai mais voilà après
c'est le premier
opération c'est formidablement bien
passé six heures de sur la table le
Seigneur avant de dormir un peu avant
après une pays se réveille
tranquillement il fait un peu des règles
des cauchemars il ne souffre pas il est
souvent fait on espère que demain il va
se rasseoir et si tout va bien pour
trois quatre semaines des hauts devoir
trouver une une vie normale on croise
les doigts
[Musique]